The SCP Foundation handles all kinds of anomalies
and abnormalities, from horrors beyond thought
to the most simple cryptids.
It goes without saying that ghosts are included
- after all, every culture has stories about
ghosts, spirits, and hauntings.
But your average poltergeists are nothing
special to the hardened agents and researchers
of the Foundation.
They’ve seen so many that there have been
studies written on their behaviour - what
could possibly still be scary about them?
In 1999, the Foundation found out that the
only thing more terrifying than a ghost is
the absence of one.
But let’s go back in time a little.
Way back in 1961, the Foundation were informed
of a little town in the Mississippi backwoods
called Pollensbee, allegedly a hotspot for
all sorts of anomalies.
The town was mostly owned by the Burnley Family
- a long lineage of magicians, occultists,
and alchemists in the Deep South, their power
so notable even the Foundation of yesteryear
decided they were better left alone.
After conducting some cursory reconnaissance
on the famous patriarch of
the family, a heresiographer
named Lyle Alan Burnley, and the ancestral
estate of Elelín, the Foundation decided
to leave Pollensbee for another day.
That day came in 1978.
Lyle Alan Burnley died, and the estate passed
into the hands of the municipal government.
That’s where the Foundation stepped in - they
had heard lots of stories from frightened
tourists of Elelín being haunted, of the
land being cursed.
They took ownership and, to their shock, found
that these weren’t just the ravings of spooked
travelers.
Elelín really was haunted, but these ghosts
weren’t hateful or malicious.
They were barely even significant enough to
be worth containment - so the Foundation decided
not to waste their resources on containing
an entire estate.
They cut a deal with the surviving Burnleys:
so long as they made sure the “Revenants”
of Burnley Manor stayed in line, the Foundation
wouldn’t bother them.
This worked great, all the way until the fateful
year of 1999.
None of the Burnleys remained in the dilapidated
mansion anymore, and the Foundation began
receiving reports of a new anomaly - classified
as SCP-6274.
The ghosts of the Burnley Estate were lashing
out - and then disappearing,
defying the Foundation’s
understanding of how ghosts work.
An excerpt written by Lyle Alan Burnley regarding
the hauntings says:
No two hauntings are quite alike, though they
share some common properties.
Let us dispel the notion that all are translucent
people wandering around after dark to scare
children - a Revenant can take any number
of forms, from a phenomenon to a place.
While I cannot speak for all of them, those
that I encountered in my home life at the
Estate were universally positive, and helpful
to a fault.
The most universal property being that they
do not leave.
The occultists of yore thought that spirits
could be banished or exorcised.
They were incorrect.
In the decades since Society learned of their
existence, methods have been proposed and
tested to permanently remove them.
All are prohibitively expensive, and none
have ever worked.
At best, their actions can be temporarily
dampened - but they will never go away.
A crew from MTF Mu-13 were sent into Elelin
to investigate the situation.
They enter to find the entire sprawling mansion
without power and in disrepair, the paint
peeling and the roofs collapsing.
They advance through the building, putting
down surveillance cameras and microphones,
trying to find the status of the ghosts.
They find a door to the wine cellar that,
against all force, just won’t open.
Behind it: the sounds of breathing.
With no choice, they draw a rune on the door
and leave, finding a dining hall filled with
rotten food.
On their way back - the rune has been erased.
They reassure themselves that there is nothing
to be afraid of, and continue into the main
hall.
That’s when it hits them - the ghosts of
Elelín are awake.
They see horrifying apparitions on their way
through to the other wing of the mansion,
where many of the doors are barred from the
inside.
The one that isn’t contains a fancy covered
bed and dozens of candles covering every surface.
Somehow, they don’t realize one of them
has gone missing.
Then something happens - something bad.
The entire section of the documentation is
expunged - when it clears up, two agents are
reporting waking up in the garden, holding
a book and looking at a tree growing around
a human body.
They rush back to the house and into the kitchen,
but the house has changed from the inside.
They find the body of the absent agent, and
a single finger coming from the bottom of
the sealed door.
The documentation expunges itself just as
the surviving agent arms herself.
When it ends, all there is left to do is for
the agent’s body to be recovered hours later
from the porch, along with the book.
The sacrifice of the agents lets the Foundation
discover a few things - the dining room, the
bedroom, and the tree are the sites of Elelín’s
last ghosts - the Feast, the Brood, and the
Totem.
The book seems to be a diary written by Mr.
Burnley, recording all the ghosts of the manor
and their history, and dedicated to his four
children.
The Foundation prepares one of their mediums
- they must commune with the ghosts of Elelín.
First comes the Feast;
The Feast is an entity inhabiting the Silverton
dining room, among the most docile of those
that inhabit our home.
As a boy, it was a favorite plaything — as
a young man, an endless source of amazement
for the ladies of the town when they came
up to the manor — as an older man, a close
confidante for when one wishes to shut out
the troubles of the world with food and drink
without conversation.
It is an arrangement of
delicacies and perfectly-cooked
meats with aged wines and all manner of side
dishes.
Roasted hams, seared steaks, cooked goose
and veal.
The exact contents change regularly — I
remember Arthur and I at breakfasts, making
a game of guessing what would be on the table
by nightfall.
He adored the room nearly as much as I. Like
many other Revenants in Elelín, it seeks
only to live in happy coexistence with the
current generation of Burnleys inhabiting
the home.
For the Feast, this means providing delicious
food, and the enjoyment that comes from a
full belly.
After much time in the family's archives in
the Library, I've ventured forth a guess that
the Feast was once Abraham Burnley, a noted
gastronome and gourmet, dead in 1845.
I have had little luck in communing with him
in the usual method — it seems he is happy
to limit his interaction with the world to
one's taste buds.
The Feast is a food-based Revenant - despite
Mr. Burnley’s claims, all it produces now
is rotten, maggot-ridden food filled with
razor blades, shrapnel, and bugs.
The Foundation’s medium, known only as Z,
sits down and begins the ritual in the dining
room.
Her cries are met with small shifts - a plate
moving, meat falling apart, a breeze.
Suddenly, she announces to her guards that
something is wrong - that there is no ghost.
An impossibly old voice speaks through her
and to her.
It tells her: There is no spirit to be found
here.
Only absences.
Only nothing.
There is nothing to be afraid of in the dark.
Then, in a whisper - that the cellar can only
be opened by the masters of the house.
Then the ritual breaks, and all parties look
to the table - where there are hundreds of
glasses of a dark wine.
Since then, the Feast hasn’t shown any activity.
A misconception — that ghosts, spirits,
revenants, whatever you choose to call them,
are utterly and totally divorced from the
world which we inhabit.
That their interaction is limited to that
of a common poltergeist (hah!), throwing vases
and banging together pots and pans like a
choleric child.
Not so.
Revenants are not altogether unlike living
humans.
They feel emotion.
They are driven by something, though they
do not know what (one could say this goes
for most all creatures).
They rage when they are upset — when they
are angry, bitter, frightened of something.
A wise man I met in Jordan some years ago
told me that every Revenant is anchored by
something in the living world - be it a person,
an object, a location.
Something that they left behind.
When this anchor is removed…
the Revenant ceases to exist.
What remains is something else.
Then comes the Brood;
As a child I was warned against going into
the bedroom in the western wing.
We all knew the one.
It was never locked (Burnleys do not believe
in stifling exploration) but I was told quite
sternly by my father that I would be solely
and entirely responsible for what I found
inside.
Decades later, I told Matilda the same thing
when she asked what was inside.
Naturally, it stopped neither of us.
None of the Revenants in Burnley Manor are
dangerous, but a fair few simply wish to be
left alone.
The Brood is one of these — I have no idea
how old it is.
I have asked everyone and searched to the
bottom of the archives, but no one seems to
know where it came from.
Presumably it does not predate the creation
of the western wing itself in 1798, but who
can say for certain?
The Brood takes the form of a woman in the
throes of childbirth in her bedchambers.
She screams, cries, and generally spurns visitors
(reasonably enough).
The curtains open for only a few seconds,
but in those seconds any questions you ask
the poor thing are answered with all the truth
of the universe.
My father was right — knowledge is not a
burden a child should bear.
Not a day goes by where I do not remember
Matilda weeping as she hugged me.
All the Brood does now is
sit inside the impenetrable
bed, constantly softly weeping and occasionally
throwing an object from inside the curtains
- though never daring to open them.
Z navigates through the candles and kneels
by the foot of the bed, requesting an audience,
only to be met with a flung baby rattle and
a woman’s soft voice asking who’s there,
demanding where her family has gone, and begging
for help - because nothing’s coming out.
Before Z can even respond, the woman inside
the bed screams for her to get the gun - then
the room goes completely dark.
The same ancient voice speaks from behind
the curtains: it informs her that she wastes
her time with ghosts of ghosts while Burnley
Manor is eaten around her - what has killed
the ghosts of Elelin, impossible as it may
be?
And what does a ghost leave behind when killed?
Once again, just as Z gets her wits, the spell
is broken and the curtains of the bed open,
revealing a burned corpse huddled under the
sheets.
The Brood, too, has fallen silent.
The Burnley ghosts are like no other.
'Haunted manors' are a dime a dozen.
Revenants angry they have been forgotten by
the world, acting out and crowd of unknowing
fools furthering their suffering.
A tragic story, by any angle.
But here — our ghosts are not unknowns,
forgotten by the world.
They are remembered — Burnleys do not shy
away from our ghosts, we approach them with
open arms.
They may be not of this mortal coil, but they
are still family, and family is the most important
thing.
Family is what we leave behind in this world.
Our legacy and our mark.
We also leave behind our spirits - our Revenants.
This book is a collection of the ghosts of
Burnley Manor and the place they hold in our
family.
The family is the anchor for all of them.
I do not like to imagine a world in which
that anchor no longer exists, and so I shall
not.
But when I walk the grounds at night — my
children have all but gone — I realize I
may very well be the last Burnley.
Without me, what will happen to this place?
The memories I have forged here with my children
— my place is to remember what my ancestors
have left behind.
What will I leave behind?
And the Totem;
The Totem is a strange thing.
I remember long afternoons spent running through
the gardens with my brothers and sisters.
The groundskeeper hated us, how we would ruin
his perfectly tended shrubs.
Then we'd be called in for dinner by the maid,
and wolf down the Feast — before spending
the evening lounging beneath the Totem.
My grandfather sat me on his lap and told
me its story one day.
His own grand-uncle had done a service for
the Indians that still dominated our land
back then.
The specifics of the service are unclear to
me - but it was great enough that when he
died, they paid their debt, and he came back,
as a sapling in the grounds of the garden
that he loved so much.
The fruit he produced were one-of-a-kind - a
large, round thing the size of your fist with
a thick purple skin and a juicy red inside.
He was our oldest family member - we adored
his stories, regaling us with cowboy tales,
and he was a tree in spirit - happy to watch
the world grow around him.
The third ghost of Elelin sits on the far
edge of the gardens, closed off in its own
little pen - the trunk of the tree intertwined
with that of a man, his arm reaching out like
a branch before being swallowed up by the
wood growing around him again.
The roots and vines have been seen strangling
and choking unwary animals and personnel,
dragging them into the corrosive soil for
digestion.
As such, Z’s communications were performed
from a small drone.
To everyone’s surprise, the Totem speaks
-- affirming he was once a Burnley, but is
now only a hole, a gap in the shape of a Burnley.
Not unlike the rest of the house - once it
was filled with the ghosts and Revenants of
old members of the Burnley clan, but something
happened.
The Totem speaks, but its voice ages into
oblivion: Something cosmic turned its eyes
on a family in Mississippi.
Leaving behind nothingness in its wake.
I was looking through my archives just the
other day when I came across an old journal
of mine, from an expedition into the Ironeye.
They have a rich and ancient culture, and
as with all cultures the aspect of mysticism
and spirituality was strong.
I shared my knowledge of certain histories
and heresies, and was provided with their
own stories in turn.
One story was of a man whose father had been
killed in battle.
He was told by a shaman that his father's
spirit, his Revenant, was watching over him,
and would continue to do so for his son and
his son's son and so on.
He was comforted by this knowledge.
Many years later, the man was subject to a
curse from a rival House.
Something to plague misfortunes upon his family.
In those weeks, he felt a presence by his
side, one he did not even realize was there,
change - morph from something to nothing.
Like a black hole on his shoulder, constantly
pulling — the unignorable presence of nothingness.
The shaman told him plainly — his father's
spirit was no longer the thing walking by
his side.
It troubles me.
I have seen what my forefathers have left
behind.
I leave behind four wonderful children and
two wives.
I leave behind a body of work as impressive
as any scholar of the paranormal.
But my children have no interest in the occult.
The family's secrets will die with me.
Whatever I leave behind will be a harbinger
of things to come.
Just as the Foundation prepared to give up
the investigation, with all three Revenants
lying indefinitely dormant, a stroke of luck
changed everything.
The Foundation was approached by a civilian
- Laura Norman, once known as Laura Burnley,
disowned by her father in the very same will
that left the house to the city.
Agreeing to speak with a researcher, she affirmed
that she had tried to avoid her family’s
legacy and had not seen the house in years.
The house being haunted was just a simple
fact of life - not something for the Burnley
kids to worry about, but instead housemates
and childhood confidants.
Then, she is told that against all logic,
the ghosts of Burnley Manor have been corrupted
and killed.
And that everything her father had written
- and disowned her to free her from - points
to whatever killed them being in the wine
cellar underneath the house.
Laura is in disbelief - not least because
the house does not have a wine cellar.
She agrees to open the door that doesn’t
exist - but before she does, the Foundation
discovers three corpses buried in the grounds
away from the house: those of Henry, Arthur,
and Matilda Burnley, Laura’s sibling, dead
for only a few months.
As Laura prepares to descend, the finger beneath
the door pulls itself back in.
Laura steps into the dark stairwell, searching
pointlessly for a light against the wall.
As she goes down the stairs, descending into
the inky blackness, Laura tells the handler
that there was a cellar under the house once
- as a child, her father took her down into
a cavernous empty space and told her he would
build a wine cellar there one day.
Then she arrives at the bottom, discovering…
nothing.
Not just an empty space.
But truly, nothing - the cellar is an endless
abyss.
As she stares out into the void, the realization
hits her: there is no wine cellar, there are
no ghosts, merely the spaces and outlines
where they should be.
Something has consumed the Burnley Manor - and
the last thing the researchers hear before
her microphone cuts out is an ancient voice
behind her, assuring her there is nothing
to be afraid of.
And her response: “Dad?”
Now go check out “SCP-2698 Haunted Victorian
Mansion” and “SCP-4153 - Haunted House
Horror - It Came from Site-9!” for more
anomalously chilling haunted house locations!